[Music]
in yikes
news submitted by sausage and eggs to go
a man who chopped off yep his own penis
and testicles says he now enjoys
intimacy more than ever he can focus now
wow I kind of know that feeling I get
the feeling it's like you're jacking off
so much every day that you can't even
think straight anymore
and just like if only I did have this
thing to [ __ ] make me think enjoy
intimacy more now no it's connection you
like you like right wouldn't after you
come and then you feel intimate you know
those few minutes we feel that into men
you melt together yeah and you want to
[ __ ] again or you just wanna go to sleep
that's maybe what you might be
experiencing there's only a few minutes
or maybe it's not as mean no I mean like
it's it cuz like my wife I want to do
terrible things to my wife I want to put
my dick in her ear even sometimes yeah
you know say if I didn't have my dick
maybe I would be nicer to her at all
times than like more into ministry yeah
that's [ __ ] funny yeah yeah I don't
know what you that's how a relatable no
it's dick [ __ ] in his ears have y'all
seen scary movie yeah okay you remember
that scene where they mimics scream too
but it's what a goes through the wind
I love those movies all right so this
guy he's 23 years old his name is Trent
from Washington DC he removed his own
testicles and I'm DIY surgical procedure
I wonder he blogged up like he did in
the DIY video it's a DIY video he did it
in his own apartment in April 2016
that's one lemonade came out so that's
like
is that how you reference things now
wait that's one adult CD came out
oh I know what AJ wasn't yeah weights up
three years so when he was 20 he did it
Wow oh that's easy math why couldn't I
have done that oh my god you know I just
said add LCD not album unbelievable I'm
so [ __ ] old you are you don't even
know what a CD is I know exactly I just
said he still use CDs in Japan okay that
maybe Japanese people got that so when
he was 15 years old
he came across this guy who is known as
a null Oh what is that a nut mutilator
no lo is man who every removed their
testicles in their penis eunuchs
so are eunuchs that's another word for
it but isn't eunuchs just for testicles
I heard that eunuchs were like ordered
by the king so then they can't
impregnate any of his concubines and
[ __ ] like so we can trust them what are
you saying
listen it's hard for me to communicate
with you because you just don't get Game
of Thrones and I come such a games of
Thrones or okay aren't you just a games
of Thrones are like last week no no like
nine days ago yeah like it and pyres you
know how they were like you know
Emperor's and kings and stuff yeah so
they would have yes concubines which is
their house fan that
yeah concubine for home well your
concubines at their hair oh I got rid of
the word it's so much fun I think it's a
kind of coffee or something is here a
concubine see with that tone it's
perfect actually looks like a porcupine
when I say it just sounds so technical
it's I'm talking about part of a car yes
occupied it's broken it's busted yeah
doesn't work and and eunuchs are usually
servants or people that work inside the
Emperor's like I guess Palace hmm but he
didn't want them to impregnate his
concubines because anybody's property
yeah like anger babies and this but he
couldn't use it if you would castrate
them to make sure that well because
they'll you know they'll be they'll be
servants and stuff but then he'll
castrate them
make sure that they don't impregnate the
combines because when the babies come
out of the [ __ ] binds they're actually
royalty now so you wants to make sure
all royalty are his keeping the family
yeah beautiful so there's this Trent and
so he did that first at first DIY thing
right in 2016 and then a year later in
2017 you know I want he did he removed
his penis Carolina motel room after you
did a similar surgery to remove his did
he have a last moment with it how did he
close it like huh what did he fall like
he used a ceramic knife mm-hmm and then
he disinfected it and then immediately
after you removed a he went to the
hospital so you got stitched up my bit
Kurtz thinking about it my dick hurts
thinking about it I know I didn't eat it
so he kept it the severed organs in the
freezer until his mom threw it out wait
what yeah Dori is a gift that just keeps
on giving look at the freezer and see a
dick and just like just start away did
she ask what her what like wow the best
part is that she kind of left in there
for a while and then she threw it out
I'm just so he only put painkillers and
then he did he did that procedure after
he I could never like I'm tired of
stared at his dick every time I get a
popsicle she's like I throw away that
rutabaga on sandals oh yeah has a theory
with sandals and rule yeah so this is
gelding the guy that inspired him to
because he's like the grandfather of
nullos oh he's like he I actually
googled this guy he has no dick he has
no penis meticles and it's just two
holes it's his butt hole in the hole for
him to pee ah in crazy ways a hole like
the vagina hole like see oh it looks
like a butt hole oh it's probably messy
it was like it probably is like a belly
button exactly and he does like a
speaking circuit or something to tell
people why they should do this to us I
don't know how he
I don't know how Trent came across this
guy but he's like the garyvee of nut
cutters so wait so for another's Miller
yeah no lows no sorry not for nullos
like Juggalos but for none then what is
it what's their wide like this is what
it says under the section what is a
mellow ain't no low also known as a
smoothie is someone who under gone
extreme body modification by having
their genitals and sometimes nipples
surgically removed the subculture does
not relate to the person's sexuality nor
are they necessarily transgender
although many consider themselves
eunuchs though the procedure is mostly
done by men there are women who also
voluntarily have their vagina stitch
clothes and clitoris removed but doesn't
Mitya brave why would you help closing
your vagina maybe your hole maybe the
whole part cuz it talks too much huh but
what was the point is it point is the
point for like to stop having sexual
desires or it's not for that or at least
not that I read in this article
according to Trent he felt like he was
somewhere between a man and a woman like
an androgynous in between and so he's
saying that he has noted a store
mannequin he has no desire to be a woman
so after coming across gelding he felt
inspired to do it and now he only uses
his bubble how do you know I don't know
yeah we need to shut down man or not
yeah we're gonna turn it off so he said
that the surgery was not that painful
that sounds pain he did it himself yeah
and that he is he has improved his
sexual performance afterwards
admitting that the first time he had sex
following the surgery he almost passed
out from the intensity and was shaking
for hours after he was like it was that
kind of an intense orgasm and then he
explained that he can still ejaculate
but that what it's the body bodily fluid
produced from his prostate
that's not the semen that's produced
from his testicles reason have any so he
mentally comes that's time we actually
physically to the prostate fluid oh yeah
on the bright side though I bet
skinny-dipping feels really good true
and running feels like because he could
actually swim in the ocean and he's just
way more aerodynamic than he ever was
well and he could go in the cold water
and he doesn't feel his balls like go
crazy he's not to explain that to
anybody how is the center of the water
the lake was really cold like I think
this is fine like you feel how you feel
if you feel like you don't belong to
either gender or whatever cool like do
what makes you feel good but the thing
I'm against here is that people are
doing it themselves I think it gets a
chord ah you guys trying to do it huh no
like they should professionally either
hospitals should probably be like okay
we'll honor this so that you're not
doing some [ __ ] motel [ __ ] like this
guy is with the [ __ ] whatever he used
like that's crazy to me in case you guys
were wondering and he does for a living
he's an IT worker did he use a cigar
cutter no it was a ceramic knife all
guillotine there's a mental component to
this those cuz there's gotta be when you
feel like you have to self mutilate
yourself like like Jesus and that's
something that's a different level man
what if it was it what what if it like
he tried hitting up physicians and I
like dude that's there's no medical
condition like or like cosmetic surgeons
and they're like nah we're gonna do that
like oh yeah and then he still has the
compunction to like be like I'm gonna go
buy ice and Tylenol induce me I
understand wrap my brain around that
because it's like you just want to feel
like yourself I just don't I just don't
understand the feeling of thinking you
know what this finger everything about
me is me except for this one finger I
need to take off because this is what
which is you yes exactly but all your
imperfections and things that you don't
want I can kinda relate because I got
boobs you know what I mean so I'm like
everything is me but this part here is
not what I want it to be so I can
understand that mindset where it's like
I wouldn't be happy until I look the way
I want to look you know
please saying that becoming anillo has
helped him overcome crippling depression
that he had where he attempted suicide
several times when he was at school and
he feels happier he feels more like
himself and
kind of feels freer innocence is he
allowed to walk naked in public
no cuz yes no he's got a but yeah isn't
but butts are allowed right no you can't
show butt crack I think no unless you
wear it unless you're at the beach you
can wear like a little thong but you
stop that some sort of fabric oh if you
were able to somehow plaster over the
crack of your ass you could walk naked
in public like this
for sure because there's no bodily part
that's what's offensive right is like
you have a dick out or vagina out or for
some reason boobies hell yeah that's bad
I guess personally they have that I mean
you could just no no nipple I think
girls get away with like these little
like things here I mean there's people
out there that turn into lizards and do
all kinds of [ __ ] and I mean back in a
day they even thought tattoos was like
the same [ __ ] like why you want to
mutilate your body no it's true at the
end of the day we're overpopulated we
should stop [ __ ] and having kids
anyway and I think people do are the
[ __ ] they want yeah just just try to be
like like when you got boobs like you
did it in a safe way that's what I'm
saying you produce more worried about
safety yeah cuz I'm like it he probably
seek that out and everyone's like
there's no reason why we should do this
we don't do this or whatever and that's
what he probably did it but like
possessions not for me but if he wants
to cut off his dick go cut your dick off
yep
[Music]
[Music]